You know I’m a big dreamer.
That’s why I tell kids,
you got to dream it,
before you can become it.
Leticia Bufoni wins the gold!
Dream.
When you want to win
something so bad,
you're ready to go,
you're amped up.
When more is on the line,
it's important that you perform.
I know who I am.
This is what I am.
The best player in the world.
Nobody outworked me
in the neighborhood.
I wanted it more.
This is my way of leading.
This is beyond basketball.
I just put every bit of
who I am into surfing.
Greatness isn't perfection.
Greatness is the ability
to overcome.
No matter what.
(Cheering)
As soon as we step on the
field, the feelings have to go.
Adversity is only temporary.
Showtime.